hi I'm peepers for Josh a mozambican do
p I want to talk to you about the look
and feel and the equipment we're going
to use for our first feature film raj
ghat for me as the DOP telling the story
visually is the most important part the
movie will be a mixture of different
styles depending on the pace and mood of
each sequence I haven't researched a
specific look what I've done for many
years now is watch many many movies and
learn from each we will not stick to a
specific visual style or even lighting
style throughout the movie depending on
the sequence we will shoot handheld or
in a serene and gravity one on legs or
on a dolly we will use all the equipment
we have at our disposal to tell as well
as we can our story and make a
compelling film to watch I feel that a
movie does not have to follow a single
visual style throughout it has to use
the style each sequence calls for as for
which camera i'm going to use well let
me tell you how I got to my decision I
used to shoot on many different cameras
when I started film school in columbia
college chicago in the early 1990s we
should shoot on 16 millimeter black and
white film we use Bolex cameras the roll
up the ones that you wind up then i used
Ariz srs and CP 16 declares many
different cameras when i returned to
mozambique in 1995 there was no film
cameras here so i had to shoot on
whatever i got my hands on and whatever
the budgets could afford all video
cameras for sure but during that time I
longed for a camera that would give me
the look and feel of the film cameras I
had shot with at school in 2007 I had
the pleasure of shooting again on film
on a commercial I shot in South Africa
and what the difference that was it was
really just going back in time in 2005
I'd read about Jim Jannard and his red
dream on the internet I followed him
until the red one was launched in two
thousand and
but I just didn't have the cash to put
down a down payment it was a thousand
dollars at that time I just didn't have
that money and well actually maybe I had
the thousand dollars but didn't have the
the rest to pay the camera so i just i
just looked and i couldn't buy it but
anyway i worked for two years and in
2009 i had saved enough money to buy my
first red one and I just closed my eyes
and threw the money at the red one and i
bought the red one and I didn't even
have lenses for it if i remember
correctly i just had that one that
camera and I had a lens that I had from
my old CP 16 that I had bought from film
school and I bought an adapter and I
used it with a red one but shooting on a
on a 16 millimeter lens on the red one
was not very much it wasn't very much
fun when we shot our first film short
film in 2009 we went to South Africa and
rented some very nice vintage designs
lenses and those were real nice lenses
to shoot on then I bought a secondhand
red zoom lens and 18 to 50 lens and I
remember shooting a whole movie on that
one lens from what was strange to shoot
on one lens the whole movie because
going from 18 to 50 sometimes you want
to go longer so what dude I used to do
if I reach the 50 millimeter mark on the
lens and I still not had reached my the
size i needed I would change the setting
on the red one and go for example from
4k to 3k and that would make it a longer
lens and if I wanted in a longer lens
I'll go down to 2k and I have a longer
lens it was fake but I still was able to
shoot all movie if you watch the movie
you can't really figure out that I use
different the same lens to shoot a whole
movie not the best thing to do but when
you don't have the money just ends up
working out 2k in 2009 in 2010 was still
a very good size too
shoot on and look so much better than I
HD then or now as time passed I saved
more money and I was able to buy my
first set of prime lenses from red I got
the 18 millimeters of 25 the 30 585 the
5100 and a beautiful beautiful 300
millimeter lens that I really like
anyway I haven't really shot with
another camera ever since well not
exactly I've upgraded the red one from
the red one to red one MX and then from
the mx2 the epic and then from the epic
to the dragon and from the dragon to the
weapon so it's been an evolution the
cameras kept on getting better and
better and better and yet even today
when I shoot on then on the MX not all
them eggs I'm surprised how good it
looks so ever since 2009 I haven't had
really had a choice i just had shot on
red for me the strengths and weaknesses
of the rebbe weapon well let me start
with the strength right off the bat raw
is the most important part of red then
the size of the frame I think 6k the
size of the our 3d files the latitude of
the sensor and now the size of the
camera in 2009 the red one was a monster
it was really big was heavy he wasn't it
was a difficult camera to shoot on just
if you wanted to put it on your shoulder
no it was heavy now the the weapon is so
much smaller and lighter i love it and
ultimately the ability to use PL glass
and changing lens mounts and putting
nikon lenses and canon lenses it's got
so many different strengths as for
weaknesses the old red one for me had
four main weaknesses its size its weight
the race at which it ate up the
batteries it was just unbelievably fast
at finishing batteries and the time it
took to boot up I remember it you should
take two minutes something to it just
seemed like it took ages but it did give
a pretty picture and it was when it was
upgraded to the MX it looked even better
I actually pulled out my red one MX the
other day and did a two camera set up
with the red one MX and the weapons side
by side and they cut perfectly well
together no problems the weaknesses of
the weapon I really can't say there's a
lot of weaknesses it's a really great
camera could have maybe a bit more
battery life maybe I even faster boot-up
but I can't really complain maybe when I
try a better camp on better camera from
red then I'll see the differences but
for another sound very nice in 2016 I
invested in new set of sheen lenses from
Duclos in LA I've been shooting on the
shins for the last few months for me one
big advantage is that they're much much
lighter and smaller than the parade
Prime's the red Prime's are heavy and
they big and they're not the same size
and they've got a heavy focus ring and
anyway the shins are much nicer they've
got a much nicer focus ring I mean
mechanically they seem to flow much
better smoother but they do breathes a
bit more than a red the red Prime's when
you do rak focusing from for me I'll
have to live with that but I'll have to
save up to buy a like a vintage set of
Zeiss lenses or the like semi Luke's
lenses but that that that will be later
that's a dream but as I figure out
dreams from my experience do seem to
come true especially when you work hard
for them to come true well I hope you
had an interesting time listening to me
speak about what I love doing help us
make this film come true thank you